Hello everyone,
merry Christmas and happy new year to
you.
I'm going to continue my 12 rules to are
in January and February.
We'll probably announce some more dates
in Europe as well for me in June,
but we'll start with January and
February.
On Saturday,
January 19th,
I'm going to be in Zurich,
Switzerland,
and then on Tuesday,
January 22nd in San Jose,
California,
Thursday,
January 24th in Riverdale,
California,
and Friday,
January 25th in San Diego,
California
and I've got a week or two off,
do some other things and then I'm going
to Australia and to New Zealand on
Friday,
February eighth and Saturday,
February ninth.
I'll be in Perth on Monday,
February 11th in Adelaide on Wednesday,
February 13th in Melbourne on the 15th.
That's a Friday.
I'll be in Canberra and Saturday in
Sydney on Sunday,
February 17th I'll be in Brisbane.
Then I'm going to New Zealand,
Auckland,
Monday,
February 18th,
Christchurch,
Wednesday,
February 20th,
Wellington,
Thursday,
February 21st Auckland Saturday,
February 23rd.
Then back to Australia because we added
some new venues to the tour which was
selling out quite rapidly.
Tuesday,
February 26th,
Sydney,
Wednesday,
February 27th,
Melbourne and Thursday,
February 28th,
Brisbane.
So I'm looking forward to seeing people
in Switzerland and in California and in
Australia and New Zealand and that
should uh,
do quite nicely for January and February
and also get my wife and I out of the
cold weather.
So that'll be good.
So,
um,
I hope to see you there.
Thank you all for your continued support
in 2018 byebye.